quatre hectares de verdure au coeur de
la ville le parc des quatre saisons
situé dans le quartier de l'aqueduc de
lavera plaisir va être réaménagé on a
une partie qui va être beaucoup plus
familial
espace vert familial pour faire des
pique niques pour y manger mais il y
aura aussi des jeux d'enfants qu'il y à
déjà mais qui vont être améliorés il y
aura toute une zone aussi qu'il sera une
zone plus culturel puisqu'on va mettre
en place un théâtre de verdure il y aura
des représentations pourquoi pas de
poésie ou de théâtre
et puis il y aura aussi des aménagements
qui sont des aménagements plus sportif
avec des tables de ping pong avec la
possibilité de faire du handball
également un réaménagement voulu par la
ville et penser avec les habitants en
octobre et novembre dernier deux
réunions de concertation ont été
organisées ce mardi le bilan était
présenté aux plaisirs oit ils n'ont pas
remplacé autant les amusements sinon le
reste l'aménagement le fait d'avoir des
arbres pour le soleil pour l'ombre cet
été on en avait besoin tout ça c'est
vraiment bien fait c'est un
on part coup j'ai beaucoup emmener mes
enfants quand ils étaient plus jeunes
j'ai envie qu'ils grandissent et qu'ils
puissent continuer à avoir de l'activité
à ce qu'on puisse venir le week-end en
famille en profite et 70 habitants ont
participé à l'élaboration de ce nouveau
parc
le projet coûtera 7 144 mille euros le
démarrage des travaux est prévu pour le
mois de février 2020